the smartwatch are you going to get one
anywhere from 350 to 10,000 do it and I
was doing all the way I'll and only
25,000 frankly I don't think we've
talked enough about it today I think we
need to talk a little bit more we do
bring a good idea when one of the
biggest companies in the world makes a
huge new product it's worthy to talk
about and none of us here are saying
that we're gonna buy it and that's where
the issue is how long it's going to take
for the adoption to take over okay hold
on a second this is the most brilliant
marketing campaign ever as per apples
want I mean honestly we're all talking
about it everyone's talking about it the
fact is there's this huge company with
endless cash and they can get all it's
free advertising amazing hats off to
them but what's why there are no details
about this that are new or exciting
tenella price tag was a little new right
what no I knew that you didn't you get
it I mean I can't think of anything that
that you wouldn't have expected that's
actually involved in this whole was
actually interesting if we move on from
the watch for a second was the macbook
when i saw it was two pounds i was like
wow that's gonna be huge I mean IDC
saying that sales could reach over six
million this year we kind of write that
off as an old product but this is a huge
development for that product line I want
one yeah there you're gonna go oh I
would as soon as it comes out and it's
trapping them like the original iPad
right so it's it's unbelievable so I
think that's the exciting part of the
Apple engagement today and not the watch
Leslie more than well I think it's
interesting that they're placing their
bets on a laptop when all we've heard is
mobility mobility mobility the watch is
definitely a bet on mobility we've heard
you know all this investment in terms of
the iphone 6 and people buying that it's
interesting i think another interesting
point with the whole watch aspect is
that analysts project that they will
maintain fifty-six percent of the market
that their ramp up to capturing this
market is so quick just because of that
adaptability and because of loss or
condition yeah my life better the
SmartWatch mark smart why aren't wires a
tiny little [ __ ] alexis Bartlett
actually there is no market there they
can I'm in a pretty thing it even
eighty-five percent of it because I'm
crazy who are they gonna be it has a
SmartWatch who my way Oh hallway they
have a killer one that actually people
really love but okay we can go on
forever but I 100 a really Oliver story
Venezuela was not an offering man by the
prime minister of Trinidad and Tobago
hold on in exchange for oil Trinidad
would give Venezuela tissue paper in
Venezuela there's a plague of shortages
for basic goods my citizens lining up
outside supermarkets for our seeking
bags of clothes detergent toilet paper
cooking oil I mean this is actually
quite a fascinating story you guys are
looking me like really and no story get
my Seinfeld reference can you spare a
square no no I'm mmm thank you friend
you know what Elaine Benes you didn't
tissue paper it's actually not a very
funny story because you know what if you
know you don't have toilet paper it's
not a pleasant world and they are lining
up for hours to get such basic products
an inflation is seventy percent in
Venezuela that's unbelievable and the
economy's gonna contract about seven
percent this year but this is the reason
this is a fascinating story what happens
when your currency no longer has meaning
or when you so joint have you know any
ability to really exchange your goods
other than literally exchange your good
kind of going fat and we're seeing the
same thing from Iran by the way in terms
of exchanging their oil for goods to
because of the sanctions all right Solar
Impulse an ultra-light plane powered
only by the sun's rays took off from Abu
Dhabi today an attempt to fly around the
world without using fuel the 21,000
miles flight will take four to five
months and is scheduled to cross India
China the US before returning over the
Atlantic I'm let Leslie talk first I
love this story it reminds me of an
amelia earhart type a situation here now
what's interesting is that worth of it
cool thing of course but they definitely
they stop in certain places along the
way it takes them 10 times the amount of
time to get to Oman as it would just a
commercial jet because they have to make
sure that they're landed and grounded in
getting that kind of Sun power that they
need to keep going so I mean I think
it's it's the way of the future it's the
Tesla from
you know of the future for playing no it
doesn't take me 10 times as long to
London is only imagine that there was an
MIT study about five years ago that
showed that pollution from planes kills
more people than plane crashes in plane
accidents so this is actually a real
concern that the pollution from planes
is actually contributing to the
deterioration of our environment all
right thank you that was actually really
interesting google ventures President
Bill Maris is saying it as possible to
live to 500 that's right 500 years old
he makes the point in bloomberg markets
magazine marah's hired futurist Ray
Kurzweil Kurzweil Kurzweil kurtzweil
thank you to help Google understand a
world in which machines surpass human
biology I do not want to live to 500 I I
don't either it's answer about Social
Security gentleman throw hands in this
case I can't wait for this issue uh
markets to hit those stands and for
people to check this out the guy looks
literally like a 20 year old oh he does
anymore Tyson yeah it's 40 but they're
also working on anti-aging things I mean
this guy is doing some pretty remarkable
work in the life sciences world and it
seems like this whole surpass in
artificial intelligence aspect is really
cropping up in our daily lives now you
see chappie at the top of the box office
and you know what they're doing over
there is premier that alone to be with
most shocking news this morning too
shabby on the box office is not there
okay I grew up in a family of
mathematicians and you know what I did
science fiction geeks and honestly this
is like you know this has been the quest
this is a Holy Grail is there beating
science is beating the one okay and
beating biology you know beating the one
end that we cannot control which is that
we all are going to die and if you have
billions of dollars what's the final
frontier conquering your mortality it's
big and also with robots if you can't
beat them join them right you wanted the
nanotechnology to be part of you
absorbing your thoughts it sort of
raises the question why she therefore i
am the whole piece on the guy on martine
who creates an android version of his
wife her wife uh yeah interesting and
one of the time five hundred that's the
end of the day
that one all right thanks so much lisa
Leslie and Matt I appreciate it